the spider-man far from home reviews are
in and everybody is absolutely in love
with this movie what's up everyone it's
Warren and the pre-screening for
spider-man far from home happened
earlier this week and the embargo for it
lifted on Wednesday so everybody has
been posting their reviews online and
they are absolutely incredible now of
course like with any movie that is
pre-screened some links are going to get
out and today we have a leak about the
spider-man far from home post credit
scene now it has been revealed that
there is both a mid-credits scene and a
post-credits scene now if you're worried
about spoilers I'm only going to be
talking about one of the post-credits
scenes and I won't be giving any
information that could possibly spoil
the movie but I'm going to be talking
about the post-credits scene that is a
call back to the original Tobey Maguire
Sam Raimi spider-man films yesterday I
posted a video about some of the reviews
for spider-man far from home saying that
the post-credits scene will make any
fans of the Tobey Maguire Sam Raimi
spider-man films nostalgic and now
thanks to somebody who has seen the
movie leaking what the post-credits
scene is we know what it is so let's
talk about what it is and what it means
for the future of spider-man films also
be sure to subscribe and stick around to
the end so you can enter my Marvel
Legends item giveaway I'll be picking
three winners when I hit four hundred
and fifty thousand subscribers so in
this post credits scene for spider-man
far from home a news outlet is showing
recorded edited footage of the final
battle and spider-man far from home
making spider-man look like the bad guy
this edited footage also exposes the
fact that Peter Parker is spider-man
now the news outlet that is reporting
this story is the one and only Daily
Bugle now of course the only person that
could be reporting the story for the
Daily Bugle is the man himself Jay Jay
Jay Jay jonah Jameson now if this wasn't
already enough to make you feel
nostalgic about the first Sam Raimi
tobey maguire spider-man films Jay jonah
Jameson and the post-credits scene for
spider-man far from home is played by
none other than JK Simmons himself
that's right the original actor that
played JJJ in the original Tobey Maguire
Sam Raimi spider-man films so although
it is not Tobey Maguire making us feel
nostalgic about the first same
Raimi spider-man films JK Simmons is
back playing his original role that he
played in the original Sam Raimi
spider-man films and of course what is
he doing making spider-man out to be a
bad guy that phone once dead
spider-man hero or menace exclusive
Daily Bugle photo menace he was
protecting that arm on Atticus you take
the pictures I'll make up the headlines
ok alright that okay with you yes sir
goodie classic JJJ although this time it
has a twist he actually exposes the fact
that Peter Parker is spider-man which
isn't really that hard to believe in the
MCU everybody knew that Tony Stark was
Iron Man I am Iron Man
that Steve Rogers was Captain America
and throughout all of spider-man far
from home everybody is looking at
spider-man to be the Next Iron Man and
now that Peter Parker has the backing of
Stark Industries and shield and his
identity has been exposed he has
everything that he needs to step up and
be the next new Iron Man so it seems
like spider-man is a very important
character to Kevin Feige and Marvel
moving forward in the MCU yes they only
have one movie left in the Sony Marvel
contract to use Tom hall and spider-man
in the MCU but of course you can always
renegotiate and make new contracts and
the man himself Kevin Feige the
president of Marvel Studios has openly
stated that he thinks that spider-man is
the greatest hero of all time so you
know that Tom Hollands spider-man is
very important to the MCU right now and
now Peter Parker's identity has been
exposed and everybody knows that he is
spider-man which makes sense because it
seems like most of his friends find out
pretty easily that he's spider-man in
spider-man far from home and leave it up
to good old JJJ to be the person that
exposes him so it looks like Peter
Parker is going to have a lot to deal
with in the next spider-man film comment
below with your thoughts on JK Simmons
reprising his role of JJJ and also your
favorite villain or superhero Doctor
Octopus and that's crap science squid
crap Doctor Strange that's pretty good
and like the video and subscribe to my
channel so you can enter my giveaway and
stay up to date on everything relating
to Marvel as Oh
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf